[Music]
a uh couple was reunited
with their biological daughter after
giving birth to the wrong
are you going to give baby to the wrong
baby
it's one of those like ask only yes or
no questions oh okay a little riddle
what you can't technically give birth to
the wrong baby it's the baby that came
out got mixed up right technically they
did so what the [ __ ] oh is it the [ __ ]
artificial insemination the pre-cum [ __ ]
oh the
breakout [ __ ]
what's the pre-cut that's the medical
the old pre-cum switch-up
they got decentralized come [ __ ]
you said
a couple has been reunited with her
biological daughter following an in
vitro fertilization mix-up pre-cum [ __ ]
which meant the mother was pregnant with
another couple's baby
so they gave they [ __ ] gave her the
wrong egg so she was hosting the wrong
egg and sperm because even because even
with in vitro sometimes let's say
let's say he's my wife right obviously
steve is my wife right i want to be your
wife okay fine
okay let bart be your wife all right
bart's to my wife okay um you'd be a
good wife bro it's my wife can bart be
my wife too
what do you what do you have i'm not in
the picture i'm the doctor he's the
husband barcelona i want to be the sperm
yeah yeah [ __ ] could be the egg
he's a sperm this is helpful this is
really helpful all right because bart's
the wife nick is the egg of bart
ryan is confirmed
of me comes out of my little dick comes
out of your ear huge penis by the way
i travel all the way through the arena
and
in regular
baby making procedure for whatever
reason ryan can not penetrate nick i
don't know right yeah right
using just trying to stop me
advanced technology like in vitro looks
like i've never had that problem
they can extract steve's sperm
extract bart's egg find the best
genetically
suitable candidates for the insemination
and then create the best chance baby
using the actual sperm
and egg of the parents
they can do that
where do they put the baby baby i like
that phrase most of the time they put
them in the mother the actual yes you
point to yourself however in this
particular situation daphna and
alexander cardinale from los angeles
they don't look they don't sound like
los angeles names they sound like
they're wearing like living
[ __ ]
there's some linen pants everything they
smell like patchouli i love that
accusation swedish and [ __ ] they don't
sound like they're like names
all right jose canseco and there we go
yeah that's it wait wasn't he
that's good spent months raising a child
that was not their fault their own
following a mix-up at a fertility clinic
according to a lawsuit filed on monday
november 8th do you think that they're
so delusional that like it looks like
you know you know it looks like you
i could only imagine i can only imagine
because you gotta like do that for how
long you're gonna do that forever bro
[ __ ] you so
pops out of black baby and then they're
like he's beautiful
to be fair it wasn't it wasn't that
pigmented but uh oh okay the couple had
immediate suspicions that the girl
definitely gave birth to in september
and 2019 was not theirs because the
child had a
different complexion
than they did
because i wouldn't i wouldn't question
if it was an asian baby i'd be like
they suppressed their doubts though
as they fell in love with the baby and
trusted doctors in the ivf process oh
dude so then they're they're going to
give it up anyway don't you love that
because they fell in love with the baby
and they're like that's still not ours
so
but after taking a genetic test their
worst fears were confirmed with the baby
not related to either parent how old it
turned out daphna had been pregnant with
another couple's baby and that another
woman had been carrying their child so
was there a switcheroo did they do a
whole here's your baby thank you would
it be so easy for you it's a matthew
mcconaughey movie i'm not a woman which
one that sounds like all of them i lose
guidance
i'm talking about everyone that he's not
a lawyer how about everyone he's not a
lawyer in you dumb [ __ ]
interstellar there is a confusion
the moms go through some crazy regimen
you know like diet lifestyle i should
have probably should and here's the
thing that's the objective stuff because
the other stuff is when you build a
personal relationship that is
incomparable
by [ __ ] harboring a human life and
developing it yeah and then when it
comes out
having nine months of relationship with
the before you've ever seen it that's
why you paid the extra dollar for ivf
right yeah so you said
yes extra dollars
you know i mean do they get a refund
they should get a refund it's just a
[ __ ] did the doctor say hey we had a
little oofy doofy
i think i could relate with women
because when i'm super constipated right
like i [ __ ] have a heart to heart
with that [ __ ] and then i let
that [ __ ] go but when it's gone it's
gone dude i'm like thank god dude it
feels like a party oh thank god for joe
i was gonna say it feels like a party is
missing but
not for you
i i wanted it gone you know so that's
i'm assuming that's how females like
they feel you know they're pretty close
were both of the parents attached to
their
new babies the the only perspective
shown to uh here is one-sided
and it says that uh from daphne's point
of view i was overwhelmed by feelings of
fear betrayal anger and heartbreak
during a news conference with her
husband announcing the lost suit that
they had no they're not that's the
they're
a [ __ ] man that's the [ __ ] angelino
and i was robbed of the ability to carry
my own child i never had the opportunity
to grow and bond with her during
pregnancy
[Music]
are you [ __ ] that up
yeah the cardinals a
complaint accuses the los angeles based
california center for reproductive
health and its owner
dr
ellaran moore
of medical malpractice breach of
contract negligence negligence and fraud
it demands a jury trial and seeks
unspecified damages what you gotta do is
you gotta sue the other baby
because you're like i connected with you
yeah and you're a fraud and yeah
i thought you were my daughter yeah hey
what was all that i felt about you but
they got they gotta serve they gotta
serve the baby they go what's your name
all
right
we'll wait two 643 accounts of
breastfeeding that didn't belong to you
yeah see i love that they thought they
got deprived but then they felt like
they had connected with this little baby
so it's like come on dude just [ __ ]
do you want to keep it or what no four
babies the two other parents involved in
the alleged mix-up wish to remain
anonymous and plan a similar lawsuit in
the coming days of course they should do
a team lawsuit
sue both babies
that's just the babies again the lawsuit
claims
in litigation
that reproductive clinic had mystically
implanted the other couple's embryo into
daphne and transferred the cardinals
embryo made from dapton's egg and
alexander sperm into the other woman bro
duh
and the babies both girls were born a
week apart in september 2019. they
[ __ ] up hard dude this clinic are they
just going to switch a roux because
that's just what it is right it's just
hey you have my baby and i got your baby
let's just [ __ ] switch
my bad it was the bonding though the
biological
cardinals including their young daughter
fell in love with this uh yeah because
they had a separate child fell in love
with this child and were terrified she
would be taken away from them all the
while alexander and daphne did not know
the whereabouts of their own embryo and
thus were terrified that another woman
had been pregnant with their child and
their child was out in the world
somewhere without them what if what are
they eating [ __ ] microwave lasagna
you know like they're just worried about
what they're feeding aaron [ __ ] you
can't feed a baby microwave it's like a
different question the babies were
swapped back to their biological
families in january of
i think they're gonna have play dates
together i think they should be best
friends they should be friendly mine is
white because dude that's a bond you
guys can't break from each other you
might as you had the baby you love the
[ __ ] baby you might as well have your
daughter but what if you don't like the
parents though you do it for the kids
though for the
do [ __ ] for the kids age i think didn't
have much of a choice however to add
more pain to the story
alive because adding pain to the story
is what we do here jayhead i hate all
other parents
daphne said breaking the news about the
mix of to their older daughter who is
now seven was the hardest thing in my
life she's seven she's not gonna
remember it dude man this is some l.a
[ __ ] i agree you should sue the [ __ ]
the company you should sue the [ __ ] out
of them because that's ridiculous
put the baby in the same outfit that the
daughter doesn't even know switch the
babies okay you guys are making play
dates
she's not gonna [ __ ] gaslight the
[ __ ] out of her
what are you talking about [ __ ] it's
the same girl be a real parent
like your child
be a real parent save her the mental
trauma gaslighter
because i swear that was a different
baby they didn't normalize gaslighting
in situations like this santa says
agreeable girls get more gifts
yeah
when they're seven seasons he's so dark
dude
how long are you gonna let that one fly
that's also what uncles say when they
wanna diddle too
but it's probably very true hey uh
santa says if you keep secrets
santa says
[ __ ] wild man
i mean this is some first world crazy
[ __ ] huh this is some la problem
i don't think they got in vitro and
[ __ ] that costs a lot doesn't it dude
in vitro is it like how much like hell
experience like you're talking at least
two bitcoins bro
you're talking about half of bitcoin
one of our friends went through it and
then there was like a really hardcore
journey because it's like people don't
go straight to ibm yeah that's the whole
thing it's a whole journey that gets
there and once you get there there's no
guarantee multiple attempts and from
what i understand it could be like six
figures and so to get a [ __ ] up on
something that has that much time and
money and emotional
investment it's crazy it's crazy
yeah damn but the love they felt for
their fake babies wasn't enough
[Music]
you